[upbeat music]
- I am always so pleased to talk to Jony.
He is of course to the design world,
either an oracle, or a God,
someone whose projects,
once as chief design officer for Apple,
now, as the founder of the
design collective LoveFrom,
a breathlessly awaited
and inspire a kind of awe.
He's also famously private
and rarely heard from
which only adds to his mystique.
To his friends though
and I am so proud to count
myself as one of them,
Jony has such warmth and
generosity and intelligence.
He is, I'd say a humanist,
a delight to talk to, a wonderful father,
and loving husband to his
extraordinary wife, Heather,
someone who cares about
people as much as he cares
about the extraordinary
things that he designs.
The products he's made, the
iPhone, the Apple Watch,
we all know the list by now are brilliant,
precisely because they have a human scale,
and an intuitive simplicity and purity,
that make them feel essential.
They're tools, but at
this point they feel more
like natural complements to
the busy lives that we lead.
And of course,
none of us know what we
would do without them.
So it's been two years
since Jony left Apple.
And I know that we're
also excited to hear about
the turns his life and career
have taken with LoveFrom,
which collaborates not only with Apple,
but with brands like Ferrari and Airbnb.
And as so much
of LoveFrom's work revolves
around climate change,
I'm especially eager to
hear his thoughts on this.
Please join me in welcoming, Sir Jony Ive.
Jony, nice to see you again
back at a WIRED conference.
I think it's about four
years since we talked last,
well, at a WIRED conference.
And these past few weeks
have marked several,
big anniversaries for you.
And so, today I wanted to
ask you about some of them.
For starters, 20 years
ago, iPod was launched.
You spent most of your career
creating devices we hold
in our hands or on our desk.
And then you moved to devices,
we wear like the Apple Watch.
What was the biggest challenge
in the shift to wearables,
and where on earth are all
these devices gonna from here?
- Well, it's certainly been,
I can't quite remember a few weeks,
that have been quite
so loaded in terms of,
important anniversaries
that have given me,
[indistinct] to think about the past.
These haven't been those sort
of dreadfully polite,
gentle reminiscences,
that these have been,
I think really fairly loaded.
The iPod, I struggle to really
get my head around that.
It is truly 20 years.
I think iPod marked
the beginning of a very
new and important chapter,
for Apple, or as it was
pre-iPod Apple computer.
So up until that point in time,
Apple made general
purpose computing devices.
And one of the powers,
I think one of the
things that was so unique
and special I think
about the computer was,
its ability to be general purpose.
And I think what the
iPod really marked was
the beginning of creating,
far more specific products and devices.
Now it happened at a time
I think of extraordinary,
I think, both opportunity and need.
So, there were a number of
technological affordances
that sort of presented themselves,
in terms of storing lots of
data in small physical spaces.
But I think the need was that
there was almost this sort
of existential question,
about the value of music.
This is 20 years ago,
when people realized they
didn't have to pay for music.
And so I think that was
a context or a backdrop,
for doing something,
creating something that
was quite important.
And I think, the iPod,
really represents that marriage of,
I think, innovative and great hardware,
software and services.
And from a design perspective,
we thought the opportunities were,
I think, exciting, compelling, but also,
this seemed important.
And so, from a design point of view,
the context back, you know, 20 years ago,
consumer electronics tended
to be plastic objects
that were really represented.
I know, I mean, they tended
to be fairly sort of arbitrary
in terms of their form.
And we genuinely,
we honestly felt that there was something
so profoundly important about music.
And so we wanted to develop a design,
that somehow acknowledged that gravitas,
that this was not another
piece of you know,
random consumer electronics.
And so I think that started
with first of all treating it
as a single system.
So, you know, the
headphones were, you know,
we thought about them
in terms of being part
of the same product, being
the actual player device.
We developed a new sort of
palette of materials that range
from double shop plastic but
to polished stainless steel
that was laser edge.
We did a ton of work on
not only the materials
but also just on the color.
I mean, now it seems obvious,
with the benefit of
hindsight it seems obvious,
to, you know, that they're
headphones would be white.
I remember 20 years ago,
the sort of shock and
resistance to, you know,
why would you possibly, call
attention to these headphones,
that where I saw is like
these little white flags,
that spoke to, you know, the
one visible part of the system.
So, I mean, the other
thing I think was that,
we wanted to try and create a design,
that was so distinctive, that
it didn't require a logo,
and a name on the front,
which is unheard of.
20 years ago in consumer electronics,
you couldn't move for, you
know, shouting about, you know,
logo and the company that made it.
And, I think what happened,
and this happens occasionally,
it doesn't happen very
often but sometimes,
a design can assume as you know,
a sort of a momentum where,
it assumes a sort of a cultural,
I don't know, gravity and significance,
and what we started to hear
about it referred to as,
as an icon.
But this did mark,
I think the beginning of moving away
from what was general purpose,
to something that was more
specific in what it did,
and more specific in who it did it for.
So it was a personal device,
that was, I mean, we started
to see people wearing our products.
- I always remember thinking
about logos and icons.
I always remember the first
time I came to visit you
in your incredible headquarters at Apple.
And you were adamant,
that there shouldn't be a shop,
that you didn't want to have a shop,
but that you said that you had realized
that actually everybody wanted to buy,
that coffee mug with the Apple logo.
So what did you ever do about the shop?
Did you have it in the end or not?
- No, we do.
I mean, Apple Park,
there is actually a
fantastic visitor center.
And as part of the visitor center,
you can buy your mugs
with the Apple logo on.
- Yeah but I seem to
remember you were very,
very against it.
So, obviously that was 20 years ago.
If we look forward to
20 years from now, Jony,
what do you think
wearable devices will be?
What do you think the future is for them?
- Well, I think what really,
I mean in many ways, I
think Apple's journey began,
in the '70s to make,
what was incredibly powerful
technology personal,
with the personal computer.
And I think that trajectory,
that journey, started then.
And then now I think there
are these salient moments
along the way,
that mark the capability,
the technology becoming more
specific, and more personal.
So I think the iPod was a
terribly important marker
on that journey.
I think another significant
one was the Apple Watch.
So as the technology
becomes more powerful,
but also physically becomes smaller,
and that it is possible for it to be worn,
worn simply and worn easily,
the products become clearly
not only more personal,
but they become more intimate.
And I think, I mean, there's no doubt.
And I know you and I have
talked about this in the past.
Without question, some
of those products will,
disappear beneath our skin.
I can't think of anything
more personal, more specific,
more individual, and more intimate
than things being insiders.
But, that's not gonna be all
of the products obviously.
I mean, while we remain physical
beings and while we remain,
in a physical world
relating to one another,
while we have our eyes and our hands,
we will also want to
relate beyond ourselves.
And so there's,
I think going to be a categories
and categories of products,
that while I think they
will be more intimate
and more personal,
but they will be worn,
outside of our skin.
- Right, right.
Well, we also talked a lot
about how we could make,
the Apple Watch smaller.
That was something you
were really challenged by.
That's something that I
would love to see one day.
But 10 years ago Jony,
the world lost your
creative partner Steve Jobs,
who you referred to as
the most inquisitive
human I have ever met.
And I read that amazing
tribute that you wrote
to him recently in the
Wall Street Journal.
So, what do you miss most about him,
the conversations, the
person, the creativity?
- Yeah, it's been an
interesting process and I mean,
I'm sure it's one that
many of us can relate to.
I think perhaps rather naively,
I thought my sense of Steve,
when I remember him and think about him
which is pretty much every day.
I thought my sense of
him would remain somehow,
inviolate and stable.
And, what's surprised me,
is as I think about him,
my sense of him,
my sense of what his
contribution truly was,
has grown and has evolved.
And I think that's a comment
on a number of things.
I think not least,
sort of the current situation and context
that we've been living
through in the last few years.
But I think where I have seen
this shift in my own sense
and my own remembering of him,
was less about his achievement,
less about his, you know,
the products of his process,
but it's become more and more about,
how he worked and the
values and the priorities,
that he had in his working.
And so, now as I described,
I've never met anybody more truly curious,
more inquisitive than Steve.
I mean, those are easy words
and they can be used fairly glibly
but he was constantly questioning.
He wasn't defined by anybody else's dogma.
There was this relish, this
celebration of being surprised,
even if the surprise actually
meant that he was wrong,
he was far more interested
in the learning,
than being right.
And it was just that love,
and that almost childlike wonder,
of discovering and questioning.
But I think,
with some space I realize,
and this has influenced me so very much.
I think it's very easy to think.
Well, you know, that can just
be an innate personality trait
to be curious.
And, over the last sort of decade or so,
I've become increasingly aware,
of actually just how much
intention is required,
if you don't want to just fit in to,
I guess the status quo or just fit
in a nice, polite, convenient way,
that large groups of people tend to,
sort of push you towards.
And I've become more and
more aware of the intention,
the resolve, and the
determination, to be truly curious,
to be truly, you know, questioning.
I think what happens,
is that when we're in a group of people,
we tend to want to talk
about what's known,
because it's much easier to
have a polite conversation.
Most people I think don't
relish confrontation
and they want to establish,
some sort of connection with other people.
And that's very hard
to do in a large group,
if what you're talking about
is partial and tentative.
If it's just a nebulous, fragile idea,
that's a much more difficult conversation,
than talking about the problem,
because I think the thing with problems,
by definition a problem is understood.
And so of course people want to talk about
what they understand.
And so generally the
problem consumes the oxygen.
It takes all of the attention.
And, I am more and more struck
by how much energy and effort,
that he put in to encouraging people,
to be comfortable talking about
what's tentative and partial.
And that's ideas.
And his just innate respect to reverence
for the creative process
was extraordinary.
And I don't know,
the older I get, the more important,
both the contribution, and I don't know,
the sort of, the moral
imperative around creating,
you know, personally seems to be the case.
And so, yeah, I am particularly mindful
of just his attitudes and his thinking,
perhaps more than the
predictable achievements.
- Listening to you Jony,
I'm wondering if these
thoughts were in your mind
when you left Apple and formed LoveFrom.
And I'd love to understand
what made you choose that name.
And could you tell us,
I know a lot of it, you can't tell us,
but can you tell us more
about the motivation
and the people behind the company?
And I believe an enormous
amount of the work
that you're doing now is
connected to climate change.
But, how much of it was spurred
by all those extraordinary,
moving descriptions you
just gave us of Steve?
Were they connected to the decision
to create this company?
- Now, I think, I mean,
that's a great question.
I think, of course it's always
a question of when, not if.
And so, the timing felt right
for me to change the nature
of my relationship with Apple.
I still work very closely
with my friends at Apple.
They're one of the collaborators
that we're working with.
But yes, without a doubt,
I mean, in terms of
where the name came from,
I was always struck by how
often we talk about what we do,
and how we do it, but we
don't often talk about why.
And I'm personally, when I'm trying to,
whether it's me interviewing
or it's I'm trying to establish,
some sort of sense of a
relationship with somebody,
I'm always personally intrigued
by what their motivation is.
And, I will never forget
Steve describing the why.
And, he said that, you know,
when you make something,
when you create something
and you do it with care,
and you do it with love,
you may never meet the person,
that is going to use what you've made.
You may never know
their name, their story.
You probably won't even shake their hand.
But, if you create with
a genuine care and love,
and I love the way he expressed this,
it's a way of expressing our
gratitude for the species.
And I just thought that
the profoundly important
nature of our motivation,
would be a good starting place
for a description of who we are.
And so that's where the name
LoveFrom really came from.
The company, I think is an unusual one
because it really is
just the very, you know,
it's the gentle gathering of,
I think some extraordinary creatives.
And it's a diverse group of creatives.
You know, we're designers,
architects, engineers, writers,
mathematicians, musicians, filmmakers.
The thing that seems to connect us,
I think is that we are,
you know, we may be known by the work
that we've done in the past,
but I think that we are
genuinely connected and united
because we believe that
our most important work,
our most important
contribution, is in the future.
And there is a real
passion and belief there,
but also a real passion and belief
in the value of collaborating,
with a diverse group of creatives.
Our work really sort of
falls into three categories.
I mean, we have one category
of work where we're working,
very close to founders, leaders,
in a sort of a multi-year relationship.
So, you know, that's Airbnb,
Apple, Amazon collective.
We just recently announced Ferrari.
But what's exciting
about these relationships
is they're more about a relationship
that transcends individual
projects but they are longterm.
And I think the value there is,
the right project
in five years time
isn't obvious right now.
And so, and I've always loved,
you know, that as a context
which is a deep relationship
with a group of people.
The second category of work and projects
that we're involved in,
really is purely for the
love, purely for the joy,
purely for the belief
that we can be useful.
And that's very project based,
and is incredibly diverse.
I mean, it ranges from
designing urban garden systems,
to working with friends
at, for example, Moncler.
It involves us working
with his Royal Highness Prince
Charles on the Terra Carta.
And there are sort of half a
dozen projects we're working on
which I would love to talk
about irritating the icon.
- [indistinct] have a love from
puffer jacket from Moncler?
- Oh, that was just the beginning.
I mean, as you said,
with huge intention
almost without exception,
all of our work is either
very directly or indirectly,
but all of our work
almost without exception,
is trying to make a
contribution to the crisis
that we're facing,
relative to climate change.
And I think that this little
group that we've assembled,
we are hoping that we can be
in some way useful in a
number of different ways
but we are excited about being useful,
and joining what is clearly a,
I've been very struck by
the diverse collection of people
who have made this their life's work.
- So you're a collective,
you're a collective?
- And you know, some of my dear friends
who I'm lucky enough to be working with.
But the collective ranges from
the legend that is [indistinct]
to the legend that is Peter Saville.
But as I said,
there is a sort of a
serenity or calm in that,
you know, I think many of us
are known by what we have done
and we are much more interested
though, in what we could do.
And I think we do believe that we can do,
so much more particularly
if we are working together.
- Together, yeah.
Well, I think it's been
such an interesting,
past couple of years Jony
and everybody reevaluating,
what it is they wanna do with their lives,
what they want to do for
other people around them.
And I'm just,
obviously you thought about
LoveFrom before COVID.
But, has COVID hastened your
desire to put your work out
into the world?
Has it changed the values
that you had in your mind
when you started it?
I mean, we've had people,
I think I was reading that two
and a half million people
quit their jobs in August,
just because they wanted
to do something completely different.
Obviously you are ahead of the curve
but I'm wondering as we emerge from COVID,
what is it that's top of your mind as you,
start to think about all
this extraordinary work
that you'll be doing?
- Now I mean, that's a wonderful question.
It's a very big question.
I think the last sort of year and a half
that we've lived through,
I think highlights,
some fairly significant challenges for us.
I do think I've been
interested for a long time,
in the relationship where, you know,
between what is digital virtual
and what is material and tangible.
I mean, it's interesting
the first shipping product,
from LoveFrom, very intentionally
but perhaps rather
surprisingly is a typeface.
And we developed a typeface.
I mean, we've been
working on this typeface,
fanatically and with such care and love
but for over two years,
but it's a typeface based on work that,
a typographer John Baskerville
developed over 200 years ago.
And we managed to track down,
the original steel punches from the 1700s.
And we scanned and redrew
all of the characters.
The type set now has over,
I think it's over 7,000
distinct characters, symbols,
and a range of different styles.
But what's been so interesting,
is that I think it's a lovely
comment on our huge respect,
and deference to the traditions
and the excellence of the past,
but combining that with a belief
about the importance of the future.
And I also think it's a nice comment,
on our struggles and preoccupation between
the physical world,
between those 200 old steel punches,
and the design of a typeface,
that is also infinitely
controllable in terms
of varying optical sizes,
weights, in the digital world.
So, I think one of the
things that has so struck me,
I mean, one of many, but has
been the slight confusion.
And of course the anxiety
that's consequent,
as we struggle to understand
what is virtual and digital
and what is material.
And as you know, I mean, I've always been,
like I think many
designers, applied artists,
I've always been a keen
student of process.
I've always spent a lot of
time looking at how I work.
I mean, in some ways it's very
selfish, it's for my sanity,
to be able to cope with those times when,
ideas neither come, or
they're just appalling.
But one of the things
that has become so clear,
while I am so grateful
for our virtual and digital communication,
the danger is it's now
so good in so many ways,
that we make that dreadful mistake,
of thinking that it is
in some way a surrogate
for actually being together in person.
And as a creative person,
you know, those sorts of very
transactional tactical ways
of being together are great for
a whole bunch of activities.
But to try and do something
new, to create something new,
to think in a different way,
it's really quite challenging, isn't it?
I mean, I think a huge part
of the creative process,
a big component of being
curious and inquisitive,
is learning to actually listen to ignore.
- You were talking about the
quietest voice in the room.
- It's so funny, I mean,
if you're on, you know,
a virtual video call,
and you're trying to
encourage people to listen,
and everybody's quiet,
we assume there's an audio problem.
So, to just be quiet
and to enjoy being quiet
and to listening and to think,
you know, video connections like these,
do not encourage us to
be quiet and thoughtful.
And I think, you know,
going back to my recollections
and thinking about Steve,
some of the most important times we spent,
were probably on walks together
when neither of us said very much,
but we were thinking in
proximity to each other.
- Yes.
- And that's the beauty
of ideas, isn't it?
That they can come very quietly.
I think almost always in my experience,
the most powerful ideas do occur quietly,
and they are fragile,
and they need to be with
reverence and respect,
gently cared for as they
evolve to become powerful.
And I've always loved that
sort of strange disconnect,
between something that eventually
can be so, so powerful,
but started so gently.
And in such a sort of a
tentative partial way.
- Jony, you are an extraordinary father,
and you have the most
extraordinary two boys that,
really accredit to you and to Heather.
And I wonder,
when you think of the kind of world
that they're going to inherit,
how do you think
about making it a more
hopeful place for them?
Because, I know their future
is so important to you.
- Well, thank you first of all.
Yeah, I mean, I hope the
world is in one piece
as they grow up.
They're both absurdly creative.
And as you know a
consequence of that practice,
is that you have to be
optimistic and faithful.
And so they have such an affirming,
and very positive view of the future.
I think, you know,
sometimes I have to bite
down and keep my, you know,
how consumed I am with anxiety.
I try and hide that from them.
I hope, that there is a way
that we can regard and place,
these very powerful technologies
and tools that we have.
I hope we can find the
right place for them,
in our personal lives and
in our collective lives.
I think that this is not a new challenge.
I mean, those tools that
are the most powerful,
that I believe have the
potential to be the most helpful.
So often we look at history,
they can be the most destructive.
And I think one of the challenges
that we have at the moment
is that we are moving so quickly.
I think we are struggling to
comprehend, to understand,
both the tremendous power of these tools.
And we are struggling to
understand the responsibility,
and perhaps the frameworks
that we need to create,
to try and encourage these tools
and opportunities to be used usefully,
and to try and reduce
the instances of them being
used in a negative way.
So I think I'm hugely
encouraged that the tools
and opportunities are there to help us,
it's just our attitudes towards them.
But I do hope, that the
world the boys grow into,
I hope there's just a little
bit more surprise and wonder,
and just an awful lot less cynical dogma.
I hope it's a world where there
is just a natural enthusiasm
and interest in ideas,
and there is more of a rejection
of just yet another opinion
masquerading as fact,
or as truth, or as even
as useful as an idea.
But again, I go back to that behavior
that we often say is childlike.
And I mean, our children are curious,
they're inquisitive,
and they want to learn,
and we've gotta figure
out a way of educate,
you know, not having that
lovely predisposition
to be curious and inquisitive,
educated out of them.
- Well, Johnny, I'm sure
that their lives are filled
with surprise and wonder.
And we also look forward to seeing all
the magical things you're
gonna create from LoveFrom.
I'm especially excited
about my Moncler jacket,
and more things to come.
And I love you, I miss
you, I'll see you soon.
- I'll see you soon Anna, lots of love.
Thank you so much.
[upbeat music]